c'est mal évidemment qu'on n'est pas
très content parce que notre clientèle
ne s'attend pas à être contrôlés avant
de rentrer dans un centre commercial
donc quand on vit ça très mal les
commerçants les clients depuis le début
de la semaine et ils sont pas très
content avec ce pass ou c'est pour tout
le monde pareil où c'est pour personne
ils ont fait ils ont ils ont voulu faire
cette loi trop rapidement sans réfléchir
pas du tout moi ce que je veux c'est que
les gens quand ils viennent dans un
centre c'est pour qu'on puisse les
accueillir
très très bien ils viennent prendre du
plaisir dans un centre commercial ils
viennent pas pour avoir des contraintes
évidemment la plupart des clients ils
sont vaccinés mais les gens ne
s'attendent pas à être allé aux portes
et c'est pas notre travail c'est pas
notre métier depuis deux ans est très
difficile très très difficile il faut se
battre tous les jours donc semer encore
des grandes tout on va encore perdre des
clients
il ya un client de perdus il faut
combien d'années pour le récupérer
vous prenez des habitudes ailleurs vous
avez du mal à revenir